[Music]  hq i'm in trouble here i need some  backup ah that's a no can do buddy all  our birds need your fuel in the last  care package  just left  all the good stuff's gone  how many doggone soldiers do i have to  kill to make something happen working on  it you're not the only hotshot in the  field  listen here hq i'm almost out of bullets  and duty can't be calling any harder  [Music]  fine i'll get some treats ready because  these guys just graduated from puppy  academy  what  what the hell does that mean hq  [Music]  thank god you're here  it's an honor to serve with you sergeant  sergeant nibbles  okay here's the point  if you take your men and you go around  here and flank them  [Music]  ripples  [Music]  no  back  door boys  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you